usted o alguien que usted quiere puede
haber sido diagnosticada con cáncer de
mama este vídeo le ayudará a entender
cómo manejarlo
el cáncer de mama es un tipo de cáncer
que comienza en las células de la mama
para muchas mujeres los tratamientos
para el cáncer de mama pueden eliminar o
destruir el cáncer
después usted debe recibir un plan de
atención con seguimiento por parte de su
equipo de atención médica
esto incluye ir a las citas de
seguimiento
su médico querrá asegurarse de que el
cáncer no ha vuelto y comprobar si hay
problemas de salud resultantes del
tratamiento
también es importante hacerse
mamografías regulares para controlar el
cáncer de mama según lo recomendado por
su médico
si usted está tomando algún medicamento
continúe tomándolo según lo prescrito
por su médico
tomé nota de cualquier efecto secundario
e infórmese lo a su médico
si usted ha tenido cirugía de mama u
otros tratamientos siga las
instrucciones que le dieron
también puede ser necesario hacer
algunos de los siguientes cambios
saludables a su estilo de vida
como una dieta saludable con más frutas
vegetales y granos enteros
una dieta saludable puede reducir el
riesgo de cáncer o la posibilidad de que
regrese
también es importante que usted
permanezca físicamente activo
actividades como caminar andar en
bicicleta o nadar pueden ayudarle a
sentirse mejor y menos cansado
pídele a su médico que les recomiende a
un fisioterapeuta o un especialista en
ejercicio que pueda ayudarle a diseñar
un plan de ejercicios adecuado para
usted y un nutricionista que lo ayuden a
diseñar una dieta o plan de alimentación
apropiado dejar de fumar y limitar el
consumo de alcohol puede ayudar a
reducir el riesgo de cáncer
y saber que tiene cáncer puede ser
abrumador es posible que tenga
preocupaciones acerca de su afección y
cómo afecta a su familia sus
tratamientos y estancias en el hospital
gastos médicos y su trabajo
afortunadamente hay maneras de lidiar
con esto recuerde que su médico y el
equipo de salud están allí para
responder a cualquier pregunta que tenga
y las siguientes fuentes de apoyo pueden
ayudarle a abordar sus preocupaciones
trabajadores sociales
líderes religiosos
consejeros
y grupos de apoyo
hablé con su médico si tiene alguna
pregunta sobre su plan de tratamiento
medicamentos o cambios de estilo de vida
que le ayuden a manejar el cáncer de
mama